joining us now is Will Prince Minister
estate for Children and Families just a
quick thought on that three people going
about their business shopping shot dead
totally appalling and in my heart goes
out and thoughts and prayers with the
the family of everyone involved is just
truly awful yeah a man appearing in
court later on today so we can't really
say much more than that at this stage
but we can talk about what on Earth is
going on with the slaves in your party
um first of all tell me for the benefit
of our viewers at home this morning
morning whatever you're watching us
um what are the responsibilities of a
deputy chief whip
so the deputy chief whip is is all about
bit pastoral care but it's also about
ensuring discipline and the management
and running of
um of parliament in an effect that in
effect the House of Commons chamber so
when you see somebody uh like Mr Fincher
behaving in the way that he did I mean
does that not bring the whole process
into disrepute well it it it's totally
appalling and I was I was shocked when I
saw the news on late on Thursday night
and then saw the resignation and then
the whip being withdrawn on on the
Friday and the neurality is Parliament
is 650 MPS and what I see day in day out
is people working hard for their
constituents and to try and make this
country a better place for not just
their constituents but everyone so
children have better life chances than
their their parents and there's no
question that allegations of this nature
and of course we've got to have due
processes to follow does huge damage to
the reputation and Trust in Parliament
and of course that hurts us all so what
do you do about it well it's right the
due process follows the first thing is
it's really important that people make
complaints and call out behavior that is
in this case what appears to be totally
totally unacceptable if the allegation
is serious of course I would encourage
people to go to the police they should
also go to the Parliamentary authorities
in particular if it happens on the
Parliamentary estate because that's
exactly the way through a formal
complaint process that action can be
taken as it was in this case with the
Prime Minister and the chief work taking
the decision to withdraw the whip I mean
it's Charming to have you uh here today
not particularly well known to my
viewers but come back whenever you want
um
I'm reading in the paper this morning
that Junior ministers are being sent out
to deal with the press and to talk to
viewers back home because senior
ministers just can't face
um defending people like the former
deputy chief
well I'm certainly not going to defend
the former deputy chief whip the
allegations are incredibly serious and
I'm appalled by them but that isn't the
case today because I was booked in four
days ago in fact five days ago I think
it was to talk about very important
child care and we'll come to the
announcement we're going to again to
come to that um but but of course the
the actions as are alleged are
indefensible I don't think you'll see
anybody come forward and say anything
other than that and given um you've
we've all heard the allegations and read
about them over the weekend do you think
they're serious enough for the police to
get involved
so I think that is a matter for the
police but I think it's important
approach of course and I think the key
thing is that we create an environment
where everybody feels that if they
witness or if they are the victim of
sexual assault or predatory behavior of
this nature in line with these
allegations that they feel able to go to
the police and the authorities because
that's exactly how investigations can
follow and due process take its course
well wonders why the Prime Minister gave
him a job
well look it's it's a fair question and
I anticipated that I I spoke with number
10 both yesterday and today and I I
asked them firmly and clearly for an
answer on this and I've been given
categorical assurance that the Prime
Minister was not aware of any serious uh
specific allegation with regards to the
former deputy chief whip seems that lots
of people around the Prime Minister were
but the Prime Minister himself wasn't so
all I can say is what I've I've heard
and that's that the Prime Minister
wasn't aware of any specific allegation
or complaint with regards to the former
deputy chief Whip and I think these
cases are hard because like any
Professional Organization you can't act
on rumor or gossip and as you know in
Westminster there is a lot of rumor or
gossip is something I try to sort of
stay clear of but it's why it's also so
important that where people do witness
something which is clearly falling well
below the the standard Behavior we
should rightly expect from members of
parliament and those who work on the
Parliamentary estate that it's reported
and we encourage everybody to come
forward and where that's the police or
the Parliamentary authorities so action
can be taken like it was in this case
with the chief Whip and the Prime
Minister the very next day with drawing
the web it took them 21 hours so well it
I don't think that's entirely Fair
because I think the deputy chief whip
resigned the previous evening and then
the next day I believe a formal
complaint was made and it was on the
basis of that complaint being made that
the whip was then withdrawn do you think
he should resign his suit
so that's not that's not a matter for me
no I'm interested in your view so it it
we've got to let you process follow and
follow its course so I would encourage
the first thing is everybody and anybody
who has witnessed or who has been the
victim of um behavior that they believe
to be below the standard expected then
they should report it and then that's a
matter for the police and the
Parliamentary authorities the reason I
ask is because I heard from the um
former MP for Tiverton and honnerton who
lost his or who actually was forced to
resign his seat he feels it's double
standards and there's one rule for what
happened with him what he was watching
on his phone in the chamber and the
physical alleged political assaults that
this guy's been up to I think every case
has to be taken on a case-by-case basis
clearly the the behavior there was
unacceptable also and do I think Neil
Parrish made the right decision yes I do
ultimately it was his decision to resign
his seat in this case now the whip spoon
withdrawn there will be a formal
investigation and the key thing is Kay
that as many people and anybody who has
witnessed or had experience as a victim
of any kind of sexual predatory behavior
comes forward reports that it is once
again challenging the ethical judgment
though of the Prime Minister is it not I
hear what you say that the Prime
Minister says he doesn't know about the
actual details but if we look back at
some of the other stuff that's been
going on not least Lord guide who was
the ethics advisor to the Prime Minister
he resigned 19 days ago at the moment he
doesn't have an Ethics advisor
that is the case I've no doubt the Prime
Minister intends to appoint one but you
know I think on this case if you look at
what happened in terms of an allegation
was made the very same and a complaint
made the very same day the chief Whip
and the prime minister went through the
whip you've now got to let due process I
understand the allegations of being
disputed so you've got to let due
process follow its course but I'm
absolutely confident that the
investigation will take place and then
the appropriate action will be taken and
if any of these claims against him are
proven he should then lose his seat well
that's a that's a massive of Parliament
and we have clear processes and
procedures in place around recall yeah
but you wouldn't be happy sitting next
to him would you in the chamber well
it's it's not a matter for me and it's
and it's absolutely wrong
is because I'm sure a lot of my viewers
this morning will think well I wouldn't
want to sit next to him the allegations
are shocking and appalling uh and and I
can understand why colleagues would
indeed feel that way but in terms of who
represents a seat in Parliament that is
ultimately up to the constituents of of
that individual Member of Parliament but
of course there are clear procedures and
processes around recall in place but I
think we're jump the gun a bit because
there is due process and we've got to
remember that investigation follows it
will all depend on the length of the
investigation and that will be no doubt
in the hands of the police and the
Parliamentary authorities okay so you
think the police will get involved I I
don't know Kate I don't know it all
depends on who comes forward talk to me
about
um your planned Child Care can I call
them reforms yeah you certainly can so
this is all about improving the
accessibility the availability and
important the affordability of child
care and early years education so it's
about encouraging more child minders
into the market which we know has been a
declining sector over the past few years
it's about ratio reforms we've got a
consultation on ratio reform and fairer
funding it's about an extra 10 million
pounds pumped into maintain Nursery
schools and it's also about generally
just looking at what more we can do over
the next few years around child care and
earliest education whilst of course
maintaining that high quality uh
ensuring that safety is Paramount fewer
off though
um first off in what way in terms of
ratios yeah well what we're proposing is
moving from a one to four currently to
the Scottish model which is one to five
and it'll be up to each individual
setting it's sort of a a Target it's a
very much a legal cap it's a maximum and
it is designed to give individual
settings and providers that flexibility
as to how they safely provide the high
quality Care within their setting why do
it if it's not going to serve any money
well I didn't say it wouldn't save money
in fact if people follow through with it
it could save money and we've we've
modeled what that would look like but at
the moment some settings and the great
thing about our earlier setting and we
have 97 that are good or outstanding so
we have some of the highest quality
earliest education in the world it's
about giving them that flexibility
whether it's around staff training or
covering lunch breaks so parents don't
turn up that day because of star
sickness or whatever else that that they
aren't going to be able to have a child
have a place in that setting in that day
so it's not saying they have to move
these ratios it's giving them the option
to do so and and that's why we're
Consulting on it and I very much want to
hear the views of the sector well you
say that but I mean you went to Paris
with hour tomorrow on Friday NFI by the
way and you said that it's not going to
save any money and it's not a silver
bullet so I said it's not a silver
bullet and I didn't say it's not going
to save money I said it could save money
but it's not a silver bullet in terms of
dramatically reducing the cost for
parents it's more about flexibility for
settings which will then ultimately in
the medium to long term could save money
but it's part of a wider package of
measures including for example ensuring
that parents who could and should be
eligible to to in some cases thousands
of pounds of government support through
entitlements through tax-free child care
and of course through the Universal
Credit offer which is 85 of child care
costs making sure that they're accessing
the entitlements that they're currently
not receiving and in some cases it's
hundreds of thousands of people that
could and should be eligible for this
funding which could be up to you know
several thousand pounds a year so will
it save my viewers money or not so it
what it will do so ratios will in the
medium to long term save money yes but
the key thing today actually is about
hundreds of thousands of people who
aren't accessing the government support
be it the two or the three and four year
old offer or indeed tax-free child care
in Universal Credit making sure that
they're getting the entitlement that
they should be at the moment which can
be worth up to several thousand pounds
now you have a little bit of a conflict
of interest in that your missus is a
teacher she wants 12 your boss wants to
give a nine percent
that's going to be tricky isn't it at
home over dinner well you're you're yeah
I'm going to be in a tricky situation
with a wife as a teacher and a senko um
so it's something we don't discuss at
home K but you know you're right I mean
these are these are difficult times and
we know that there's the global global
inflationary pressures and the
government has to tread that path very
carefully we have independent uh salary
and pay review bodies and it's important
that we wait for those recommendations
and don't prejudge them okay I can't let
you go without talking dogs we we're
both yes look at his face light up as
soon as I said there we go there we go
we're doing a story later on about
posters being attacked by dogs
apparently
um something like thousands are attacked
um every year are they bad dogs or bad
owners
well I I it's probably a mixture of the
two in terms of it's really important as
you know okay when you get a dog that
you invest the time to train them
properly I think there are steps that
everyone can take at home so you know
when we've had a dog at home and as you
know we look after our neighbors and
when I've had them with my parents you
can put guards over your letterbox which
can prevent these things from happening
like cages that catch the post and also
if you alert the post office they'll put
a red sticker against your address to so
they know that there's a dog on the
premises so I think it's about being a
responsible dog owner okay I always
think there's no such thing as bad dogs
just bad owners
um thank you very much you did Minister
for joining us much appreciated thank
you very much indeed